thank you all right that things on good
morning thanks for thanks for waking up
on a on a Saturday morning I know I'm
sure many of you would rather be
sleeping in this is early for a group of
programmers so I have several things
that that that I'm going to to talk
about I have a lot of talks that have to
do with just a summary of what I'm
working on and whenever I give something
more like more like a keynote I try to
also talk about things that they go
beyond that and extend to you know the
community and some of the things that we
can that we can do together as a as a
growing community to you know to work
better toward you know common goals and
in the future so I'll talk a little bit
more about that as the coffee kicks in
and thanks again to the organizers for
for having me here and to numb focus and
and the you know the Paideia organizers
for putting this conference together
it's really amazing to me you know going
from a small group of under a hundred
people at Google in 2012 at the first PI
data meeting I guess we can't I can't
even call it a conference it was just a
meeting at Google with like 75 people in
a room and now we know we have
conferences all over the world and you
know thousands and thousands of people
so it's really really wonderful to see
and it's been enabled by you know
supportive community and you know many
you know too many too many people to to
think so I've been doing I've been doing
lots of things the last few years most
of you know me from from my work
creating creating pandas and the book
Python for data analysis which you know
four years later has become you know
it's a standard text on learning to use
some of the some of the Python some of
the Python data tools
spent now I guess you know you work on
problems for for many years in a row and
all of a sudden you look back and you
say well I've spent almost a decade
working on you know a certain set of
certain set of problems I didn't expect
in 2007-2008 to spend the next you know
eight to ten years working on creating
data tools but that's what ended up
happening which is there's nothing wrong
with that
but it's allowed me to be involved in a
bunch of bunch of Python projects and
now I've been getting involved in the
apache software ecosystem we'll say a
few words about that but not a whole lot
has changed
I started out of Python programmer ended
up doing a lot more C and C++
programming which is which is that
turned out to be quite nice so if you
haven't been doing any C++ 11 or 14 you
know now there's no better time than now
to to learn I'm kind of glad that I
skipped C++ programming until it turned
into suddenly modern C++ it's a much
more much more friendly environment you
still have build tool chains to wrestle
with and that's no fun but as soon as
you get your build system set up
programming in C++ is now quite quite
nice I am working on a second edition of
a Python for data analysis the first
edition has held up surprisingly well
most of the code still works there if
you you know I've spent a lot of time
with the book you know that there's some
there's some code that is broken or with
pandas there's some things like axis
indexing that you know the dot IX is now
no longer considered a best practice so
there's some things that need to get
considerably revamped in in the second
edition so I have my work cut out for me
but look out for that if I can get my
act together probably early next year
when it hits hits bookshelves but
hopefully we'll have an early release
from from O'Reilly before that
figure out my water situation so I
wanted to say a few words about building
open source communities and I can't
claim to be an expert in in building
open source communities there's other
people out there that who were much
smarter than me and have been doing it
for doing it for a much much longer time
but I think for all of us it's something
to to reflect on as the Piatt as the pie
data community continues to grow and
becomes larger and larger and I think by
and large we haven't had to deal with
with that many problems I I think that
overall you know pie data is a pretty
well socialized community full of you
know helpful people you know we produce
a lot of great content you know blogs
tutorials learning resources you know I
think the and you know the the you know
positive all the you know good people
and the community have been a major part
of what's helped it helped it grow to
this point but as communities grow you
know inevitably you have to start
thinking about how how to engineer the
community to continue to grow and
flourish in a positive way and so our so
our friend Peter Hitchens who gave us
AMQP and 0 mq and a lot of a lot of
technologies that have really shaped and
influenced our ecosystem as well as many
other you know as a prolific programmer
who's you know designed I think like
over 30 protocols and you know he's
dying of cancer and he can't stop
writing and you know committing on his
projects and writing books and so it's
it's really really an amazing person but
it's interesting that somebody who's
who's been a prolific open-source
software developer ends up writing about
you know basically how to build online
communities and so if you haven't you
know read this book there's he has some
other books I want to check out but
thinking about how to how to engineer
the environment so that you get you get
the right behavior out of the group of
people that are that are in it and I
have a few thoughts about things that we
can do and things that we are already
doing well and can continue to do well
to to function well as a community and
I'm also kind of seeing some of this in
the Apache software ecosystem as I've
you know gotten involved in those
projects so so one of the biggest things
especially when we're working on open
source software and now a lot of our a
lot of the software that I am working on
and that many of the people in this room
are working on we may be building open
source software but we're spending the
time that we're spending building it
maybe part of our may not be volunteer
time we're working in a salaried in a
salaried job and we happen to be
building open-source software on the job
but at the end of the day you know we
have to we have to collect a paycheck
and so it's very important when you have
a group of people who are all working on
open source software as part of their
jobs to understand what is what is
motivating what is motivating their
decision making why you know why are
certain things why are certain things
important to them and so whenever you're
disagreeing about something that you're
able to see the other person's the other
person's perspective and sometimes
people don't always don't aren't always
upfront about when if if they're arguing
really passionately for for something or
pushing the software in a certain
direction to understand you know what is
motivating that you know to help kind of
others to understand you know it's so
the you're putting in the effort to
understand other people's problems and
what other people need as well as you
know communicating your your your you
know your motivation so that other
people can see your your purse
I think in my work what's you know I've
always spent a lot of time trying to
understand the the needs of the needs of
users and to put myself in the shoes of
people who are using people are using
pandas or other other python libraries
because it's not just enough to build a
piece of software that works for you and
you design a function or an API and it
solves the problem that's right in front
of you but as soon as you know you
published publish that software it's a
pie pie people install it they start
using it and they run into a bunch of
problems and I think one of the worst
things that can happen in open-source
communities is project maintainer x' see
somebody struggling with a problem they
say oh well it works for me so you know
patches are welcome but you know you
kind of on your own
so maybe not spending that much effort
to be helpful to to kind of build the
community and get more developers and
users users involved which brings me to
kind of my second point which is
reaching reaching out to others and in
when you build a new open-source project
and you spend you know the feedback
cycle you know you write a piece of code
and the time it's all you're actually
getting feedback on that code is
generally a very long time so my rule of
thumb is about six months and so you you
know you make a new release of a
software it takes people a long time to
even find the new features that you that
you build maybe they're stuck on an old
version of the library and it takes them
a while to be able to you know upgrade
it and make sure that it didn't break
their applications to try out your new
features and so and this can be really
difficult the first time that you you
know you're but you you release software
and you're not getting immediate
feedback about the you know the Python
code or the C code that you just you
know spent all night you know working on
or you spent all weekend it's been a
weekend working on but
the feedback does eventually come if
you've you know if you've built
something that other people want to use
but you also kind of as a as a developer
and as a user you know coming to
conferences and engaging engaging with
others to sort of learn about their
learn about their use cases but also to
you know if you're building a new
project to bring other to reach out to
others to try to bring them into your
community to figure out if there's ways
that you can be collaborating if there's
anything that you mutually can be doing
to be to be more useful to understand
those each other's problems and say like
oh I can build this and you can build
that and then eventually we can meet in
the middle and we have something where
the whole is greater than the sum than
the sum of its parts another another
thing that is that is diffic stream lis
difficult especially in open source
projects that grow to many many
developers is having a commitment to to
consensus driven development and not all
projects necessarily need to proceed on
the on the basis of of consensus but it
is very tempting so especially when
you're the person who created a project
so for example so for example pandas you
spend you know a couple years of your
life building a piece of software and
then all of a sudden you have a half
dozen additional developers who are
spending their nights and weekends or
maybe their day jobs working on working
on the library and so it's natural even
though you have other core developers
working on the project it's natural for
you as you know create over project or
somebody who spent proportionately a
very like a larger amount of time than
other developers it's natural to feel
some sense of entitlement to be able to
to to make to make decisions or to push
forward to push forward changes that
maybe not everyone agrees with and it
does take active effort to put in the
energy if you are if you want to make a
decision or you feel strongly about
something to spend the effort to explain
to explain your reasoning and to try to
you know basically with a bunch of very
different people in the room arrive at
some mutual understanding of the problem
and a consensus about what is the what
is the way forward
and consensus is a lot harder than you
know it's kind of like democracy in a
way like it's you know it's kind of
easier to be a dictator and to lay down
the law but you know consensus takes
takes real work I think the Python
community in general has done a good job
of this and even income or Python with
with Guido being the benevolent dictator
for life it's very rare that the this
the special privilege of the of the be
DFL is is invoked I think another thing
that we can do that is very helpful I
find is very helpful is to really put a
lot of value on contributions to the
community outside of the code the code
itself and I think there's there's some
there's definitely a we have a we all
have a cognitive bias that and I and I
do as well that you know the code is the
code and it's the gate you know it's the
get commits and the poll requests and
the and the bug reports and it is a lot
of work to build build working software
and you know it maybe it's 80/20 or
90/10 or 95 5 but you know all of the
work that goes into you know making
dependable scientific data analysis
software that we can you know that we
can build you know kind of our
professional lives on you know it's a
lot of work and a lot of it is very very
unglamorous programming you know you're
chasing down some kind of numerical you
know precision bug that ends up being
you know you're down a rabbit hole for
three days and eventually you find some
crazy bug and you're trying to explain
it to your collaborators and
you know it's you know the esoteric
stuff that that you run into and
building these projects it goes largely
unappreciated by the users but there's
there's many contributions and beyond
that you know being helpful to to users
helping teach and educate people new
people coming to the community being
tolerant of all the you know I guess
there's no dumb questions but you know
it's you know there's there's a certain
you know you could like many communities
just tell people to read read the effing
manual but you know it's I'm always
amazed when you know people go out of
their way to be kind and helpful to new
people in the community rather than just
you know dropping them like a link to
the documentation for a project and sort
of being patient and helping you know
people be successful there's also the
community organizing and of the
conference conference running you know
the online online community maintenance
community maintenance web web presences
and all that so it's not just building
the projects I think that you know
making the community successful is way
is way more than just writing code and I
think over time I think early on in my
career you know I felt more as like oh
well as long as the code works but it's
there's much more than that if you want
to grow beyond a small group of you know
of scrappy scrappy hackers you have to
be you know be able to embrace a much
larger and more diverse community
another thing that as we grow I've also
been concerned about and luckily it
hasn't ended up being all that much of a
problem in our community but something
that that we all collectively will have
to be on our on our lookout as you know
imagine if the PI data community grows
ten times as large as it is now
if you look at you know PyCon now with
like five or you know four or five and
thousand people at the at the major
North America North America Pike on the
first pike on that I went to in 2010 was
only about 1500 people so the Python
community itself has grown grown
significantly and as online communities
grow inevitably there will be that small
subset of people who are making things
worse for everybody
making things worse for everybody else
and one of the challenges in growing the
community is is arraign is is its
engineering kind of the rules and the
social behaviors of the communities so
that things are made harder for those
you know what you could call called bad
actors if you read like a lot of Peter
Hitchens he does talk about these these
bad actors who make things worse for
worse for everyone else so things like
like codes of conduct you know that's
why I like sometimes you'll see you know
somebody making an online ruckus about a
conference that doesn't have a code of
conduct but this is actually really
important so if you're at a conference
and you see somebody who is a bad actor
that you can say hey like you're
violating the code of conduct and you
know that is not acceptable behavior and
we hold ourselves to a high standard but
if you don't have those those social
contracts and rules in place then it can
make it harder to deal with a
problematic person because you know you
get into this you know the situation
where it's like you know I did this
thing and I didn't think that was so bad
and I don't see what you're so upset
about but you need to say like you know
here's why this is offensive or here's
why you know you're making things worse
for everyone else and so that you can
weed out those those bad actors and so I
think it's amazing that Peter Hitchens
wrote a wrote a book about called the
psychopath code you know about bad
actors in general for a like a pretty
broad definition of bad actors so I
think a lot of people think of
Psychopaths as being like the you know
serial killers you know kind of really
really bad people but if you expand the
definition of psychopathy to include
people with
you know antisocial personality
disorders it's actually you know a
shockingly high percentage of the
population and unfortunately MIT
programming does attract a lot of people
with personality disorders so so there's
something so this is there's some stuff
to watch out for there as a great book
if you interested it or you feel like
there's been a psychopath in your life
that has has drained you of your energy
or you feel like you might have a
difficult person and you try to
understand like why can't they see my
perspective like why why are we having
such a hard time communicating and why
does this person seem to not understand
that they're there they're draining the
life out of all of us you might say like
well they could be a psychopath maybe
they just aren't incapable of feeling
feeling empathy like it's a real there's
a real thing I will also say that that
mastectomy with bad actors that that
with the the nature of the internet and
Twitter it is very easy for for things
to escalate out of out of control and as
tempted as I've been to call out bad
behavior on Twitter and in public forums
I'm always a little bit careful to press
the Enter key because it's it's
difficult to you know it's hard to
continue know to know like when
something is going to go viral and when
you might potentially be doing a lot of
damage to somebody's reputation that
wasn't intended so a book on this
subject by you know not necessarily an
endorsement of Jon Ronson but an
interesting book on this subject about
public shaming people online there was
the high profile dongle gate from Pike
on several years ago which you know you
know turn into just a giant mess you
know over over this on so there's you
know with with the internet it's it's a
double-edged double-edged sword and
dealing with bad actors
luckily we have we have organizations
that are helping us grow grow the
community so it's really it's amazing
that we have have num focus now
providing a financial conduit for funds
to reach open source projects so that
businesses that are depending on the
software in this ecosystem can give
money and support support pandas or
support scikit-learn or Jupiter or any
of these projects I also work and
started working on the Apache Software
Foundation because I'm doing some big
data stuff and which serve serves some
similar goals one of the things I like
about the Apache Software Foundation is
that in addition to the fiscal legal
relationship with with projects that
Apache projects also have a social set
of rules around how the project's
operates the things like consensus
driven development merit you know the
focus on if you want to be an Apache
project you have to be able to
demonstrate that you can grow your
developer base and that you can be
inclusive and bring people into the
community and part of that clip and part
of that inclusiveness is being open and
transparent and carrying out all public
discussions on public mailing lists so
that it doesn't you know so I think
projects can devolve into a secretive
cabal of developers who are get together
and have whiteboard discussions and make
all the decisions about a project so if
you're a budding open source developer
and want to get involved in that project
he might arrive and say well I see a lot
of code that's getting written but I
don't really understand who's making the
decisions or where the discussions are
taking place so one of the things I
really like about the Apache ecosystem
is that there is a very you know
ingrained part of the culture is that if
the discussion didn't happen in public
on the mailing list or in the view of of
the world on the public record that it's
it's the same as if the discussion
didn't happen at all
so make make decisions in public and
that also is is
part of rooting out those bad actors so
that if there is somebody who is acting
in a in a way that is harming the the
developers that they're doing it in a in
a place that is part of the public
record so that you can point to and say
hey like what you did there was not not
okay and you're making things worse for
the rest of us so let's say a few words
about everyone's favorite topic which is
Python packaging I swear we spend
probably you know 20 or 30% of every
Python conference talking about
packaging luckily it has gotten a lot
better but it's it's a hard problem and
you think about all of the stuff that
has that you have to get right to be
able to to do packaging well just having
you know reliable and reproducible
infrastructure on all of the platforms
where we work you know it's not even
just Linux OS 10 and and Windows you
also have people on you know Solaris and
other kinds of exotic exotic
infrastructure but at least you know the
main platforms we can settle for let's
do things well that's a hard enough
problem so now we have things like like
the many Linux you know project which
you can you can Google about for you
know making building binary binary
wheels for that work on on many many
many Linux distributions but outside of
just being able to get consistent
environments for building the packages
there's also the issue of the build tool
chains you have to set up compilers you
have to have the right you know the
right compiler options you have to have
build scripts for all of the projects
that work on all the platforms
integration testing whenever you change
a dependency of some other downstream
project you need to have some way and
this is something that we don't do a lot
of is knowing whenever you you bump a
version of a dependency of a project
like what impact does that have on all
of the downstream dependencies and it is
you know still possible to get your you
know to get your
your Python environment or your Conda
environment into a broken state because
of you know because of dependency
dependency issues we're still building
for multiple Python versions like Ian Oz
fall and and others I'm hoping that in
in a couple of years we can just just
build for for Python rather than Python
and legacy Python aka Python to having
built you know now single code base
Python two and three projects I would
rather just build for Python three and
I'm trying to do that as consistently as
I can but still there's a lot of to
seven users out there you have to be
able to host and distribute the packages
also cut as far as the hosting and
distribution in a lot of businesses you
may be dealing with I don't know to any
of you at work any place that has air
gapped machines that don't have access
to the outside Internet we've got it
we've got a few of you so you know
imagine if you can't access pipe ipython
org immuno there's situations where you
know that is a requirement and so being
able to mirror package repositories and
to be able to pip install or Conda
install in the in the exact same way you
know behind a firewall or in an
air-gapped environment is a requirement
that that you know that some some
research labs and companies have and
it's still a very hard problem and we're
also building multiple applications to
being able to manage multiple
environments in a seamless way you know
I think you know we've come a long way
you know with with Conda and kind of you
know current jennife of packaging tools
that have made this quite a lot easier
so I think even now like new people
coming to the community part of the
reason that the community has grown
large is that the the packaging tools
have gotten a lot better and I think
back seven or eight years ago when I
started doing Python I was sort of
existentially afraid that
my efforts to build pandas or the
library that would become pandas and you
know to do open source software in
general you know or to continue to do
Python we're going to fail because I
couldn't get all of the libraries
working on on the the machine of the
person who was sitting next to me and
I've spent more time and this was on
this I was using Windows at the time I
had no choice but to use Windows and so
I had spent more time than that I'd like
to remember you know force quitting
Python exe and rerunning numpy
installers and matplotlib installers and
then testing things out manually to make
sure that I had a you know the same
environment on my machine as my
colleagues machine so it's a world
different a world different now and and
that's something that we should never
take for granted that when something
just works out of the box and you have
you know a docker file or you know build
a seiche that sets up your Python
environment the fact that that just
works is something that we should you
know really feel good about but it takes
a lot of work and one thing that I'm
really really excited about is this new
project which if you haven't looked at
called Conda Forge which is a a set of a
set of tools and a workflow for for
writing for writing new recipes for for
Conda and deploying them into a
community governed and managed
environment where the the build and you
know the build kind of upload and
management of those of those packages is
is automated and all handled on on
public public infrastructure on github
and not necessarily open source
infrastructure you know things like
Travis CI and circle CI these various
like you know free for open source
continuous integration services they
aren't they aren't open source but they
are free which is which is which is very
nice and I think one of the great things
about Kona forage is that there's a lot
of packages out there and especially new
software that hasn't become important
enough to be maintained officially in
one of the
enterprise distributions like the
unthought distribution or anaconda but
we still want to be able to condon
install that and make that available to
people you know to anyone who's using
using anaconda in a you know in a make
it just as easy as installing numpy as
installing you know a brand new C++
library or Python and C++ package that
you built the you know they can condon
install that and it works just just the
same so it's a really a really cool
project and there's a lot of tools that
that you know Phil Ellison and Kyle
Kelly and others have have built um you
know folks from continuum are also
involved in kana Forge and have helped
make it make it make it possible so
basically it there's some automated
tools that that that's set up what are
called feedstocks on on github and it
uses a mix of circle CI Travis CI and
app fair to build respectively for Linux
OS 10 and Windows and then upload those
the built packages to anaconda to
anaconda org so you can add Khanda Forge
to your to your contest setup right now
and and and install packages from that
from that channel so on the on the
technical front and not to spend spend
the whole the whole keynote talking
about uh stuff I'm hacking on right now
but the the technical things that I'm
likely to spend the next couple of years
on so the first thing is is enabling the
the data science communities beyond
Python to be able to collaborate or at
least have some points of of technical
collaboration so that we aren't always
you know I think unfortunately in the
past and this is part of the community
growing the community is that you know
if people are encouraging language Wars
or
so I got it yeah trying to spill on my
laptop
and I think that's this is something
that we can all do that if you know you
see somebody I think there was a point
where if you go back seven or eight
years ago and I've been guilty of this
as well that it's okay to it's okay to
punch up sometimes and I think when we
were first starting to do data analysis
and statistics in Python it really felt
like we were the the small people in the
room and there really wasn't anyone
paying attention to us and say hey like
we should be able to run regressions -
and we should be able to do statistics
in in Python and so there was it was
easy - it was easy to pick on the the
our folks and say well are is weird and
you know has a language with a lot of
words and then you know years later it's
like oh we're still having the same kind
of our vs. Python debate and you know
over time I think both of those the the
competition has been good because the
software has has matured and you know
our folks have built stuff you know kind
of out of a competitive spirit to make
are better for the day for data analysis
so so because so some good things have
come out of the language Wars but I
think they're also they're also
counterproductive in in many ways and
the the thing is the fact that we all
share common infrastructure you know
with Julia there's LLVM and you know C
C++ you know we can share code with
Julia we can share code with our you can
write C++ libraries that you can rap in
our rap and Python there's a lot that we
can do to share code and and to share
ideas between these communities now that
I work at at Cloudera and work on on
some big data problems making sure that
python can talk to these systems
efficiently has become really important
and also kind of looking at how people
are using python and how the data itself
is changing so we aren't just dealing
with multi-dimensional multi-dimensional
arrays anymore dealing with a lot more
like web data jason
data making sure that the Python tools
are growing to meet the needs of of
changing kind of evolving data data
formats and data data representations so
I think and so kind of building on on
Olivier's keynote yesterday that a lot
of people have started to say that that
Ram is becoming the becoming the new
disc and so you know I don't know that
we ever expected to have terabytes of
DRAM although maybe it's it's maybe it's
inevitable but another thing that's
happening outside of the growth in the
growth in DRAM is that the performance
and latency of solid-state disk and DRAM
are converging and they aren't going to
become equivalent but the you know
hundred X or thousand x performance
difference between I don't know what the
exact numbers are between you know
spinning rust and and DRAM but it's
there's been a definite convergence and
with the the new generation of flash
which you know if you should read about
let you read about 3d xpoint form from
Intel which is next-gen next-gen Flash
technology you know 500 to a thousand
times faster than the NAND flash and
also you know memory that is you know
non-volatile memory so you can have
application data where you make a change
in a data structure in in an application
and that change is immediately
persistent on disk so that if you know
you pull the plug on the machine you
daren't losing application state so
there's very interesting implications
there and I think in in the in the
future what we're going to see is you
know you'll have like a multi terabyte
working set like this is the data set
you know all the data sets of interest
for a particular data for data science
problem and you all have many different
consumer applications which are grabbing
pointers to memory kind of in that
working set and are using a mix of
you know hopefully at some point there
will be some kind of abstraction to make
you know manually managing memory of
like is it on disk like is it in RAM you
know kind of the out of core problems
that were that we're dealing with today
that there's more of a that the there's
more of a consistent way of like I just
addressed memory and the operating
system handles like whether that's in
RAM or on disk like it's just a pointer
and and the virtual addressing is
handled by the operating system system
kernel but there's challenges with this
model because you know it's easy to make
like these simple diagrams and say okay
well that's great we have like a couple
of terabytes like it's some of its in
RAM so if it's on disk and we've got
multiple processes reading from it like
how that seems great like let's let's do
that butBut there there's complications
because and the biggest one of the
biggest complications is you have many
different processes that want to to grab
a pointer like a pointer to this data
and say ok I want to like you know do a
pandas group by operation or I want to
you know perform some linear algebra
like fit you know do some feature
engineering and run scikit-learn on on
some memory that's in your working set
but any given system and this might be
like an AR process or a Python process
or a scala or in a c++ process in
general the system's have different
memory representations so they use
different different data structures and
what happens is that when you want to
pull pull data from the working set you
have to perform some conversion between
the storage or the you know the way that
the data is stored in the in the working
memory and the in-memory data structures
of that process and so you're spending a
lot of CPU cycles converting data
between one data structure and another
another problem is the metadata so being
able to describe from one system to
another you know what is the data like
what are if it's a table what are the
data types that you have a consistent
way of like
turns out one of the biggest problems in
numerical data is decimals so if you're
if you're dealing with databases double
precision floating points are often not
enough and so you end up down the rabbit
hole of different decimal
representations scale and precision and
in different ways the decimals are
handled and so just being able to talk
about like I have decimal data and this
is how it's represented on disk is very
very important there's also the issue of
who owns who owns the memory and how do
you know when you're you're done with
done with the data so that it can be
evicted too to cold storage and moved
out of your your working set so these
are all you know reasonably unsolved
problems but they have solutions within
certain subsets of the certain subsets
of you know different different problem
spaces and so if you've been in the
Python ecosystem for for a long time
you'd say well we already have a
solution to this problem like the
solution is numpy and it's true for for
many problems that if you think about
you know the role that numpy played in
bringing together the Python scientific
computing ecosystem the fact that we
have this common array data structure
which is built on like okay here's some
allocated memory and then here's
information about how to interpret that
as a multi-dimensional array we have
metadata that we all that we all share
which are the numpy d types and so it is
true that numpy has a whole computing
computational framework attached to it
where if you look inside a numpy data
type like there's a function table which
says okay here's how here's how i some
elements here's how i pull elements from
you know select and index elements from
an umpire array so there's there's
computation connected to numpy data
types but you you can think of them
really as just providing a description
of what the what the memory is but the
way that memory is shared
processes is handled on a case-by-case
by case basis so there's some things
that numpy doesn't solve as well so
things like you know JSON like data you
know in pandas we've we've had to hack
around and build our own our own missing
data implementation representation
handling of you know strings and and
category types so like II neumes factors
you know not not built into numpy
although there have been some efforts to
to do so in the past that where we
basically struggled to arrive at
consensus about how to deal with with
inu more categories and numpy which is
which is very unfortunate
and there's also memory representations
designed for analytical workloads that
are common to databases so I think numpy
was never really intended to be the part
of a database back-end and there's a lot
of interesting research work that's been
been done in in-memory compression and
you know kind of designing for kind of
scan based kind of database like
workloads and a lot of if you look at
pandas internally a lot of pandas
internally looks like a sort of small
like a small database so I've been been
a part of a new project called called
Apache arrow which I'll tell you briefly
about which attempts for a certain
narrow subset of these problems to build
something that will work for the for the
big data ecosystem and something that
Python can participate in so we first
have all spent a lot of time to forge a
collaboration amongst a large set of of
Apache project so these are mostly
mostly Apache projects although I was
involved from from pandas we've gotten
some our folks involved and so the goal
was to create a memory representation
for tabular data
that in and of itself within a
particular application has
characteristics that make it very fast
for for doing analytics and memory but
that we can also use for you know for
that like shared data like common
working set that we can move data
between systems or that we can reference
data and shared memory between two
processes and we have a consistent way
of sharing memory without conversion
between between systems so the so the
columnar kind of tabular part of the
problem is really just about CPU
efficiency so if you have a table of
data
traditionally in databases you have
record oriented data and it used to be
that you know this was you know kind of
old you know older older architectures
were transactional based databases this
is the way you would want the data
stored so for every row you have that
data packed in a tuple and then store it
on disk but with columnar data all of
the data that has to do with a
particular column is stored in a
contiguous memory region so typically
you might have very wide tables where
you're only interested in a few columns
and so whenever you're addressing that
in memory usually usually you're
scanning down one column and so the CPU
is very good at using CPU cache to you
know to better to better utilize that
utilize the CPU you can also do things
with with in-memory compression Delta
encoding you know different kinds of
there's a lot of research on this
subject where you can you can compress
the data in memory and to take advantage
of the cache kind of decompression
trade-off where you can actually
decompress the data out of CPU cache
faster than you you know to break
through can memory bandwidth barriers
which is which is really interesting a
lot of analytic databases have done have
done work there for me the biggest
benefit of this project is the the N
choose to problem of building
murders and data adaptors to connect
system a to system B but every time you
add a new storage system a new
computational engine to you know to the
smorgasbord you've got to figure out
like okay how do I make pandas talk to
this file formatted to this to this data
database and you end up building a
bespoke connector from one system to
another and there's a lot of you know
redundant code spent converting between
data structures and different memory
representations and so one of so what
I'm hoping to do with arrow is to to
simplify the the i/o point of contact
for pandas users with the rest of the
ecosystem so rather than saying okay I'm
gonna build like a custom adapter to you
know to hive or Impala or you know Park
a file format that that we're just
getting Aero memory back and then there
is some cost associated with converting
to and from pandas and an arrow but that
is all things considered not not the end
of the world
the Devils in the details of course so
one thing that we we did just for fun is
I saw I saw Hadley Wickham from the our
community in in January and we talked
about we talked about arrow and ways to
make our and python more interoperable
and and Hadley said well you know we
don't have as many binary file formats
in our as you do in Python and it would
be interesting if we could share data
frames between r and python a lot more
easily so we designed a small file
format called feather which uses the
apache arrow memory layout to put the
bytes on disk and we just and we came up
with a metadata that was sufficient for
describing schemas both in python and
our but in a in a language agnostic way
so that our can say like this is my
factor and on the python side i can say
okay i know how to convert an r factor
into a pandas category d type
because the file format is so simple it
you're basically just mem copying bytes
off of disk and there is limit of
conversion but most of the work of the
project is in defining the metadata so
that are in Python can communicate the
shape of their data to to each other so
the code looks basically the same in
both languages and we just run a demo
and I'm supposed to do code demos at a
Python conference is this working okay
look I'm running our code at a Python
conference okay so I'm generating a data
frame that's about a gigabyte and then
calling the right feather function which
writes it to test dot feather and then
okay okay so I'm importing feather and
Python
so then I read the data frame and
feather and so that was a gigabyte of
data so here's our here's Python and we
move a gigabyte of data from from Python
to R in a matter of seconds so that's
really very nice and the goal of feather
was not to replace any of the existing
you know HTF five or you know data
storage tools that exist for pandas but
more to build something that enables
code sharing and more interoperability
between it between r and python so what
we so what we have is a we have a small
small C++ library written in C++ 11 that
interacts with the file format and then
cyclin bindings for for Python and our
cpp bindings for our so most of the code
is in the core in the core library and
then there's a little bit of data
munging to convert between our data
frames and pandas dataframes
the nice part of the project is and I'm
running up against my time limit it's
very it's very fast it's not as fast as
native you know hdf5 pandas stuff but
it's it's it's pretty fast and you know
you you it's close to disk speed in a
lot of cases the downside is that you
have to convert between pandas
dataframes and the arrow kind of memory
representation whenever you're writing
and reading from disk so a couple of
words before I get off the stage here
one thing that I'm working actively on
right now from-from
OVA corn with uber corn from blue yonder
as we're building an arrow based adapter
to the park' columnar file format in c++
so I've been working on the oops the
park' c++ implementation the arrow c++
implementation python interface and then
you'll be able to get panda's data out
of park' files hopefully in the next
month or two and install the packages
from the pad at least initially from the
Apache
kondeh channel this is very cool and
very grateful to have the help from the
the blue yonder folks so let's get my
last slides but if if these sorts of
problems are interesting you join the
community all the activity is on the
mailing list and that's all I have so
thank you for for listening
yeah I think we have a few minutes for
questions if there are any kind of few
of our volunteers grab some mics any
questions I had a question about the so
you talked about in the beginning of the
in the beginning you talked about the
kind of getting the community involved
and I was just interested in how do you
because I often find that for for people
that are new to projects is usually
easiest to get involved in like
contributing to documentation but that
can be quite daunting because you do
need to actually know roughly what the
code is doing so how do you bridge that
gap how do you get the new people in
quickly and but but also efficiently so
it doesn't take too much of the core
developers time yeah it's it's it's it's
hard I think um you know what one thing
that helps on on on github is is you
know marking marking issues is like like
ramp up tasks or like kind of excessive
like whenever you see something that
maybe isn't urgent like doesn't need to
get done urgently but as an accessible
task that you clearly mark it as such
and that when new people come in they
say I want to write documentation or I
want to I want to fix some bugs or like
adds add some new features that you have
someplace to point them to to get
started but it but it is hard because
you know understanding the codebase well
is often necessary for writing the
writing the documentation
I think improving docstrings is like you
know because a lot of documentation is
auto generated by Sphinx from docstrings
so you know I think the quality of all
of our docstrings could be made way
better and it's just part of learning
and using a library say well okay this
wasn't clear to me and so it at least
encouraged like continuous Docs during
improvement you know a lot of libraries
half the docstrings are out of date okay
I think there's a good good nod to
everyone go and fix the dog strings in
pandas
first of all thank you very much for
your talk and I also like that you
mentioned social and as well as
technical issues my question goes to one
of your claims that fine
you made the claim that the number of
people with personality disorders under
programmers is higher then I suppose the
general population do you have a V any
evidence does it claim it's it's purely
anecdotal so it's hard it's hard to
measure but I guess it seems that it be
I don't know it'd be nice to put some
it'd be nice to put some numbers on it
but III find that the the the field of
programming you know given that we're
doing but you know bits and bytes and
writing writing programs does you know
at least in my experience does attract
more people who are kind of you know
quote-unquote on the on the spectrum but
you know who knows definitely and sorry
yeah definitely there's no selection for
social skills but my anecdotal evidence
direct to is a different direction that
most seemed rather heavy and there's
something it could be that the ones with
the personality disorders cluster at
certain places and that the SSO just
sorry yeah I I would say oh I guess I'm
gonna get kicked off here but I think um
it's exacerbated by it's not that the
higher percentage of programmers have
personality disorders but the nature of
the online communities that the people
who do it's very easy for somebody to
troll like Linus Torvalds and like stir
up some stuff on you know so it's like
if you are if you you know derive
pleasure from like driving people crazy
like the Internet provides you like a
direct way to like get in touch with
somebody that you want to troll so
yeah yeah yeah I thought you meant
possibly leave lyrics cordovan
okay let's let's tank quest again